Don Schwarz:
I'm gonna hang out back here.
Toby Reyelts: Well, looks like
everybody's settled.
Hi. I'm Toby Reyelts,
and this is Don Schwarz with me.
And we'd like to talk to you
about Java support
on Google App Engine.
First what we're gonna do
is we're gonna give you
an overview
of Google App Engine itself,
and then we're gonna talk
specifically about
Java support and detail.
And then we're gonna do
a quick demo,
and then we'll give you guys
a chance to ask us questions.
So you're probably
asking yourself
what is Google App Engine?
Well, the obvious answer is
we're a cloud-computing
platform.
But that's kind of vague.
What does that really mean?
It means you get to run
your applications
on top of Google's
infrastructure.
This really means
that we provide the container
and the services.
And there are basically
two kinds of cloud-computing
technologies out there.
People refer to them as either
infrastructure as a service
or platform as a service.
And what we provide
is platform as a service.
That means hardware,
connectivity, networking,
the operating system,
the JVM you run on top of,
the servlet container
on top of that,
and even Google's own
software services.
We provide
all of that for you.
The key features
of Google App Engine
are that you don't need
to install or maintain
your own stack.
So everything that we just
talked about in the last slide,
all of those points--
if your hardware fails,
for example,
we'll bring in new machines
automatically.
If your operating system
needs upgrading,
we'll install--we'll upgrade
the operating system for you.
If there are security patches
that are needed for your JVM,
we'll install those
security patches for you,
all transparently.
We do the scaling for you.
So we'll dynamically allocate
resources to your application
as it gets more load.
So we'll just transparently
bring in more resources
to scale it up.
You get to use Google
scalable services.
Google has a lot
of well-proven software,
and we really scale
with that software.
So what we're doing for you
with Google App Engine
is we're giving you
that software to use
via proven standard APIs
that you're familiar with
and are even portable
to other Java platforms.
You only get charged
for what you use.
Because we're able
to dynamically scale
the amount of resources that
we apply to your application,
that means we don't have to
dedicate a bunch
of hardware, right?
So that means we also
don't have to charge you
for all that dedicated hardware,
especially
for peak usage, right?
And peak use
looks a lot different
than normal use might look like.
And for this very same reason,
this means that it's always
gonna be free
to get started
with Google App Engine.
And finally, we provide you
with a built-in
application console.
And with this console,
you're able to get an overview
of how your app's doing.
You can control
certain aspects of your app.
You can monitor...like it
provides graphs for it,
and you can even
diagnose problems
that are occurring with it.
Schwarz: So let's talk
a little bit about
the architecture
of App Engine.
At the top level, of course,
we have clients.
So typically,
these will be web browsers.
They may also be mobile clients
such as iPhone Applications
or some other programmatic
HTTP client.
These clients communicate with
a set of front end processes.
These processes
know very little
about individual
App Engine Applications.
They're designed more
to provide
application independent
functionality
such as serving as
SSL endpoints.
But their primary responsibility
is to forward requests
on to a set of AppServers.
At any given time, your
application will be loaded onto
at least three AppServer
processes,
and the front ends know how to
dispatch requests appropriately.
There was also a load balancer
that is not directly
in the serving path
but essentially,
it monitors the load
on the individual AppServers
and is able
to reschedule applications
based on incoming demand.
Let's take a closer look
at one of these AppServer
processes.
There are a number of
applications
loaded onto this AppServer,
including all of the resource
files and code necessary
to execute requests.
There's also an API layer
which allows those applications
to access the outside world
or other pieces
of Google infrastructure.
So now let's talk about when
you would use Google App Engine.
When is App Engine
a good fit for you?
Primarily, we're targeting
web applications.
This means that incoming
requests need to be HTTP
or HTTPS,
and individual requests
are limited
to 30 seconds of runtime.
At the moment,
we have no support
for long-running background
processes,
So you may, for example,
be used to spinning up
a background thread
that waits for some condition
and notifies clients
or performs some task.
What we provide instead of that
is cron functionality
where you can periodically
schedule tasks,
and you receive a callback
when it's time to execute
that feature.
We also have no support
for server push right now,
so hanging gets or Comet,
those techniques
are not currently supported.
But we hope to allow that
sort of thing in the future.
We also run your requests
in a sandboxed environment.
Now, for Java, that means
that there's a Java
SecurityManager installed
which limits your access
to some features of the JVM.
There's some additional
security restrictions
which we'll talk about a little
bit later in this talk.
Reyelts: So now we've reached
the Java support section
of our slides,
and these are the topics
that we're gonna cover.
First we're gonna talk about
servlets
and how you work with those
on App Engine.
Then we're gonna talk about
the Google software services
that we provide for you,
the APIs.
Then we're gonna talk about
sandboxing,
which is the restricted
environment
that you run
your application in.
Then we're gonna talk about
the Development App Server.
That's actually a local version
of the app server
that you run
on your own desktop.
We're gonna talk about
deploying to Google servers
and how you get your application
up into the cloud.
And then we're gonna talk
about tooling,
which is all of the tools
that we provide
in the STK for you.
So for the Servlet API
for App Engine,
we give you a full Servlet
2.5 container,
and that includes
the kind of things you'd expect
with a container.
It gives you
HTTP Session support.
It gives you JSP support.
The Session support
for App Engine out of the box
is both persistent
and distributed.
And what that means,
for example,
is that if you have...
if in one JVM you put
a value into the session,
you'll be able to retrieve
that same value
in a different JVM
out of the session.
It also means that those values
are gonna persist
across machine failures.
We use Jetty and Jasper
in App Engine,
and we're really happy
with them.
But what really happens
on the production server
is that we're powered by
Google's internal HTTP stack,
so what's receiving
connections there
is all of Google's software.
And then by the time
it reaches the Java runtime,
we have Jetty involved,
and Jetty is actually
acting as an adaptor
between Google's HTTP
serving stack
and the Servlet 2.5 API.
And because of that,
that means that there
really is no support
for Jetty's specific features,
because Jetty is not
the workhorse here.
It's not actually
providing a functionality.
So that means no jetty-web.xml,
it means no Jetty continuations.
And because of this, also,
our choice of Servlet container
is subject to change.
So you shouldn't be programming
to that in general.
For example, if we find
some other container
that we're happy with
and does more functionality
for us,
we'll switch over to that.
So like other
Servlet containers,
you configure your application
using a web.xml file, right?
A serweb.xml file.
But for App Engine we add
an additional configuration file
into the mix.
It's called an App Engine
web XML file.
And this is the simplest example
of that configuration file.
There are two elements here.
One is the application element.
The second is a version element.
So App Engine
supports versioning,
which is really cool.
You can have two different
versions of your app
running at the same time.
Actually, multiple versions
of your app
running at the same time.
An example
of where you might use this
is you might have both
a production version
and a QA version concurrently
up on App Engine.
Here's a more complex version
of the configuration file.
We introduce
two more elements.
One's a static files.
One's resource files.
We allow you
to distinguish between
static content
and between dynamic content.
And we do this because
we're able to really optimally
serve static content.
And because we can
optimally serve that,
that means, in the end,
you're gonna be charged
less money
because we don't
have to dedicate
as much resources to it.
It also means
that your response times
are gonna be lower,
because we serve these
out of like caching servers
and things like that.
In this version,
we added system properties.
You're able to both configure
system properties
and environment variables
for your JVM
so you can get at those
via your application.
And finally,
you're able to both
optionally enable SSL
and HTTP sessions.
The reason we do this is because
there's a performance hit
associated
with these two features.
And by default, we don't want
every single application
paying for features that
they don't have to actually...
that they don't actually
take advantage of.
So you're able to turn those off
as you need.
Don is going to talk some
about software services here.
Schwarz: All right, so we don't
only provide a Servlet Engine.
We also provide a number
of software services
which allow you to
leverage Google's infrastructure
or to perform tasks that would
otherwise be difficult to do
within our sandboxed
environment.
For example, we provide
an Authentication API
which allows users
to log into your applications
using their existing
Google Account.
We also provide a datastore,
which allows you to store data
in Bigtable,
Google's scaleable database,
which is used in virtually
every Google product.
In terms of caching,
we provide a custom version
of memcache
which has been optimized
to run on Google servers.
And we allow you
to send outbound emails,
and we use the same
mail gateway for that
that's used to send
Gmail messages.
So obviously, there won't be any
scalability concerns with it.
And we also provide what we call
the URLFetch service,
which is a way to send HTTP
requests out of your application
so you can access web services
or retrieve RSS feeds
or scrape web pages--
anything like that.
And that uses a caching proxy
which is shared
not only amongst
all App Engine Applications
but certain other Google
services as well
so you get the benefit
of a large cache.
Let's talk a little bit more
about how you use
these services.
The top level--we try to have
a standard interface
on top of each of our services.
So for example,
JDO, JPA, JCache, JavaMail--
these are existing standards
which we've provided
adaptors for
so that they will use our
services behind the scenes.
These are entirely optional.
You're free not to use
the standard interfaces
if you'd like.
however,
they serve two purposes.
They allow you to more easily
take applications
which were written
with these services in mind
and port them
to the App Engine environment.
Now, I'm not gonna say that's
always gonna work perfectly
out of the box in all cases.
In some cases we only provide
a subset of the standard.
But at least it's the same
technology and the same class,
and it should make it
much more easy
to port your application
to App Engine.
It also allows you
to take your application,
which was written for App Engine
using these services,
and put it on
another hosting provider,
should you choose to do so.
Below that we have a set
of proprietary interfaces.
These were written by us
in Java,
so these common Java idioms
should be very simple
and straightforward to use,
and they provide just the
minimal subset of functionality
that the underlying
service supports
so there's no cruft
or unsupported features.
Below that, we have
a language-neutral interface.
So this is built
using Protocol Buffers,
which are a language-neutral
data serialization format
created at Google
and since open-sourced.
And this allows us to have
one definition of each service
that's shared amongst both
the Python and Java runtimes
of App Engine,
as well as any future runtimes.
And below that, of course,
we have the implementation
of the service.
So when you're running your
application on Google servers,
this simply dispatches requests
to the underlying
piece of Google technology
which actually
implements the service.
However, if you're running
your application locally,
we actually provide
stub implementations
of each of these services
which lets you run everything
on your local work station.
So...why do we have all these
layers of indirection?
Well, it's for two reasons.
It facilitates evolution.
It allows us to basically
change each of these layers
while having a minimal impact
on the layer above it
and ultimately, a minimal impact
on your own application code.
It also provides consistency,
so any validation that we
enforce at each of these layers
will be consistently
validated--
consistently implemented,
whether you're running
on Google servers
or testing your application
locally.
So when you actually want
to use one of these services,
you'll use something called
the App Engine API jar.
This is a jar that we provide
which contains
all the proprietary APIs
I just talked about
as well as a full implementation
of JCache and JavaMail
and our adapters for them.
Our GPA and JDO interfaces
are provided in separate jars
which depend on
App Engine API jar.
An App Engine API jar
has a release cycle
that's somewhat different
from the wider App Engine
release cycle.
Major releases
are reserved for
breaking API changes.
So for example,
if we remove a method
or remove a class or change Java
serialization compatibility,
we would reserve that
for a major release.
And in order to pick up
a major release,
you would need to actually
get the new jar from us,
recompile your application,
and redeploy it.
Patch releases,
on the other hand,
we would use for bug fixes
and new functionality
which won't break existing Apps.
These happen
much more frequently.
And it's important to note
that upgrades
to the latest patch release
happen automatically.
You don't have to redeploy
your application.
You always get the benefit
of the latest patch release.
Now let's talk
a little bit more about
where your user code
interfaces with the actual
service implementation.
We call this point
the ApiProxy.
The ApiProxy is something
that's invoked internally
by the proprietary APIs,
and it deals purely
with byte arrays,
which are serialized
Protocol Buffers,
so it doesn't know anything
about individual services.
The ApiProxy stores
a singleton delegate instance
which knows how to dispatch
service calls.
And it also stores
some per-request information
in an environment object
that's stored per thread.
So if you want to use
the API stack
that we've been talking about
outside of the App Engine
environment,
there's two things
you need to do
to configure the ApiProxy.
One is to set
a custom delegate
so that it knows what to do
with service calls.
And the other is to set
an environment
for the current thread.
So to make this easier,
we provide a class
called
the APIProxyLocalFactory
which has a custom
ApiProxy delegate
that simply locates
service implementations
on the class path
and dispatches requests to them.
So this is very useful,
for example, in unit testing
where you may want to
unit test your code
that depends on the datastore
either directly
or indirectly via JDO and JPA.
You may want to unit test
this in-process
so you can use this to find
the in-memory based
implementation of the datastore
that we provide.
So why am I telling you about
the ApiProxy?
It seems like kind of
a low-level detail
of our API stack.
Well, you can do some very
interesting things
if you know about
the ApiProxy.
You can essentially intercept
any service call.
This allows for a form
of aspect-oriented programming
across our service stack
where you basically can
intercept individual API calls,
do some logic before
or after them,
then continue on
with the original logic.
This allows you to do some
profiling and debugging
within the production
environment,
which you might not
otherwise be able to do
by, say, attaching a debugger
or a profiler to Google servers.
So here's an example
of doing exactly that.
This is basically a custom
ApiProxy delegate
which wraps around
the default delegate
and provides a little bit
of functionality
before and after
each service call
to record the time
of that service call
and log it
for future reference.
Reyelts: So now I'm gonna
talk some about sandboxing.
So the kind of thing we do
in sandboxing in App Engine
is that we restrict
dangerous JVM permissions
and we whiteList classes.
Now, the kind of JVM permissions
we restrict
are things like file permission.
File permission,
your network permissions--
things along those lines.
The way whitelisting works
in the sandbox
is that we take a subset
of the JRE
that we determined is safe
and that we've audited for that,
and we make that available
to applications.
If an application
tries to load a class
that's not on the whitelist,
they end up getting
a no class def found error.
Why do we do this?
Well, for a few reasons.
The first is that
many of the restrictions
that we have in place
just don't make sense
under clustering.
JVMs kind of spin up,
and they go away
as your application
gets more load or less load.
In fact, if you compare
a lot of the restrictions
that we have in App Engine,
you'll see that there's a huge
similarity to, like, EJB
in terms of the restrictions
it has.
Second reason is to protect
applications from each other.
We don't want, like,
Joe's evil application
attacking your application
and reading your data
and doing bad things
in general.
So by having a protective
sandbox around that,
we keep that kind of stuff
from happening.
The third
is quality of service.
We don't want things
actively preventing us
from being able
to scale your app
and provide more resources
to it.
The kinds of restrictions
under sandboxing
are threads, networking,
file system,
Java2D and native code.
And let's talk a little bit
about each of those in detail.
For threads, you can't create
a new thread under App Engine.
What you can do
is you can modify
the state of your current thread
or otherwise inspect it.
Something that we're working on
and we'll hope to have soon
is an asynchronous API.
And the way the asynchronous API
would work
is that you'd be able
to make multiple API calls,
let's say to the datastore
or to our fetch service
or something along those lines,
all concurrently in parallel,
even though it's happening
on a single thread.
For network connections,
we don't allow you to establish
a server socket
or arbitrary, outgoing
network-bound connections.
Instead, we do let you
establish HTB connections,
and we'll let you do that
via any of the
java.net.url-based classes,
like HTB URLConnection
Java.net.url,
so on and so forth.
The third has to do
with the file system.
We don't let you write
directly to the file system.
We'll let you read anything
that you upload with
your application, however.
If you do need to store data,
there are roughly three places
you can do that.
You can either do it
in your JVM's local memory,
in which case it will neither
be distributed nor persistent.
You can do it in memcache,
in which case
it will be distributed,
but there'll be
no guarantees about it,
and it won't be persistent,
or the datastore,
in which case
it'll both be persistent
and distributed,
and you can even wrap
transactions around it.
Java2D...Java2D is kind of
notoriously hard to secure.
There's a lot of native code
potentially involved with it.
There are drivers
for graphic subsystems,
things like that.
And so for right now,
we can't allow that
in App Engine.
What we do offer up
as alternatives
are an imaging API
which allows you to provide
various transforms
like compositing
or resizing or things like that.
and if you're able to get a hold
of a software rendering library,
those should generally work
under App Engine okay.
And finally,
you can't obviously upload
arbitrary native code
to App Engine.
Instead, you're just gonna
have to stick to pure Java.
So...we really want
App Engine to be
as flexible as possible,
and so we try our best to make
the sandboxing very flexible.
But a problem with this
is that we can't just implement
it with JVM permissions.
They end up being really coarse
most of the time.
They give you this little
tiny cramped sandbox
to work in, right?
Or they let you blow up
the world, and, uh...
so we try to give you
a happy medium
between these two worlds.
Let's talk about reflection
as an example.
There are two JVM permissions
surrounding reflection.
The first is
suppressAccessChecks.
The second is
accessDeclaredMembers.
And what these permissions
allow you to do
are to get at the private
fields of objects
or even call private methods.
Here's an example
of very bad, evil code.
What it's doing
is it's getting a hold of
the private account field
of the string class,
and it's changing the value
of the string object
from 11 to 2.
Now, you could see
how this could be bad
in all sorts of ways.
We don't allow this kind
of use of reflection
under App Engine.
However, this code right here,
this is nice code.
We do allow this
to run under App Engine.
What it's doing
is also inspecting the private
field of an object,
but it's doing this
on an object
that's been uploaded
with the application.
So it's the application's
own code.
This kind of abstraction
breaking
is used all the time
in libraries
like for serialization
and RPC, for example.
Let's talk about another
example--class loading.
There's a single JVM permission
around class loading,
and it's createClassLoader.
And if you have this permission,
you're able to create
your own user-controlled
ClassLoader,
and if you don't,
you're just out of luck.
Well, here's an example
of bad code
that doesn't work
in App Engine.
You can try to create
a ClassLoader,
and if you could,
you'd be able to assign
arbitrary permissions to it.
So any code you loaded
with that ClassLoader
would be able to do anything
in the world that it wanted to.
So you can see how that
would be a bad thing.
On the other hand,
what we do allow you
to do in App Engine
is create a ClassLoader
which allows you to dynamically
load byte code.
So the differences between
these two ClassLoaders
is one is assigning
arbitrary permissions,
and one is just defining
new byte code.
And there are many, many,
many libraries
that will define new byte code
on the fly.
So in the end,
what we see is that...
a flexible sandbox means
that you have high compatibility
with existing libraries to--
for example,
dependency injection frameworks
like Guice and Spring...
these libraries
work under App Engine.
Aspect-oriented programming
like AspectJ, Spring AOP,
these libraries work.
Web frameworks...
Google Web Toolkit, Tapestry,
BlazeDS,
which is a Flex library,
and Grails were happy
to just announce that
that is now working
under App Engine.
And finally, one of
the really exciting things
is that we have alternate
JVM languages
all working on App Engine.
Scala, Rhino--
the whole list goes on.
And some of these languages
compile directly down
to byte code, like Scala.
Other languages on this list
like JRuby
generate byte code
on the fly.
Schwarz: So we've hinted
a number of times in this talk
that we have a local
development environment
that allows you to test
your application locally
on your workstation
before you deploy it
to Google servers.
We call this
the DevAppServer.
It's essentially
a custom version of Jetty
which tries to emulate
our production environment
as much as possible.
And one way it does that
is by providing
a local implementation
of each of the software
services.
So for example,
there's an in-process version
of memcache.
There's also a disk-backed
version of the datastore
which has different
performance characteristics
to the production server,
but logically, it provides
the same functionality.
There's also a version
of the URLFetch service
which uses Apache HttpClient
to make outgoing HTTP requests.
It's important to note
that you're always using
the entire software stack here.
So even in the DevAppServer,
when you call a method like
url.openConnection,
we could simply let
the JVM do its default behavior
in that case.
However, that wouldn't provide
quite the same level
of validation
and wouldn't set quite
the same headers
as our production environment.
So instead, we actually
re-implement url.openConnection
in terms of
the URLFetch service,
both in the DevAppServer and
in the production environment,
so they behave consistently.
We also try to emulate
as many of
the security restrictions
of the production environment
as possible in the DevAppServer.
There are some restrictions
that are very difficult to do.
For example, some of the things
Toby just talked about
with class filtering
or flexible sandboxing
we don't perfectly emulate
in the DevAppServer.
But we're constantly
working on that
and trying to make it more
like our production environment.
So now you've tested
your application locally,
and it's time to deploy it
to Google servers.
There are two places
that your application can live.
It can either live on a custom
sub-domain of .appspot.com
or you can run it
on a custom domain
which you've either
registered through Google
or another DNS provider,
and you can point your
IP address at Google servers
and serve your application
on that custom domain.
We provide command line
and IDE-based tools
to deploy your application,
which consists of uploading
your static files
and resource files,
as we talked about,
as well as some other
metadata.
So, for example,
to efficiently...
handle your datastore queries
on our servers,
we need some idea of what sort
of queries you're gonna make,
and we need to build indexes
based on that information.
So there's some metadata
that's uploaded
at deployment time.
Also cron job descriptors
and a few other
configuration pieces.
And after that,
you're going to want to go
to the Admin Console
which is a web-based
management console we provide.
It allows you to see dashboards
of your application
as well as to view
its log files.
We have integration with
the java.util.logging package.
So if you have log statements
in your code
or in libraries
that you depend on,
all of your log statements
will automatically be indexed
and imported
into the Admin Console
for later viewing
or downloading.
So now you've deployed
your application.
It's ready to serve requests
within minutes--
or seconds, I should say.
And now it's time to actually
get some users.
So App Engine is always
free to get started.
We provide some number
of resources to you
on a daily basis for free.
For example,
6.5 core hours of CPU time,
a gigabyte of both
inbound and outbound bandwidth,
the ability to store 1 gigabyte
of data in our datastore
and to send 2,000 emails
a day.
If you need to go
beyond these limits--
hopefully your application
will be wildly successful
and you'll need to--
you can just purchase
additional resources from us.
And the way that that works
is you simply provide a credit
card via Google checkout
and set a daily budget,
which you can break down
across these categories.
And we guarantee
that on any given day
you'll be charged
only for what you use
but no more
than your daily budget.
There's also an additional limit
we should discuss here
which is that non-billing
applications
are limited to approximately
100 hits per second,
and that's actually
a lot of traffic.
But as soon as you sign up
for billing,
that jumps to 500 hits
per second.
And if you need
to go above that,
we simply ask that you give us
some advance notice
by filling out a form
so that we can go above
that level.
We just need to know
that you expect it.
Reyelts: So now we're gonna
talk some about tooling.
What we've just introduced
in our last release
of App Engine
is what's called
the SDK Tools API.
And this is an open API
that provides support
for command line tools,
Ant-based tools,
and IDE plugins.
The kind of features
that we provide in the tools API
are deployment.
This means that
there's an API
to get your app up into
Google's App Servers.
There's an API for launching
the Development App Server,
and otherwise controlling it.
There's an API that provides
the WhiteList for you,
and this allows things like
IDE plugins
to provide compile-time
checks across your code.
So, for example, as
you're developing your new code,
you're able to see that
you're using classes that
the sandbox doesn't support.
And it also provides
XML validation
for things like your
appengine-web.xml files.
Google Eclipse Plugin
is a great example of this.
We have that available
on our download site,
and if you get the
Google Eclipse Plugin,
it'll provide almost
all of these features.
And it's available
on the download link
with the STK.
And Intellij just recently
announced
a plugin that supports
these kinds of features too,
which is awesome for you guys
who like JetBrains.
So I guess that brings us
to our demo now,
and I'm going to have to
take a second
to bring that up
on the laptop over here.
Schwarz: Wanna give
the slides first?
Reyelts: So before we go
through the actual demo,
we're gonna show a few slides
and talk about it
just a little bit.
The whole point of this demo
is that it's a game,
and it's based on
the Translate APIs that...
the translate service
that Google provides.
And if you were to play
this demo,
the first screen you'd be shown
is this login screen
where you'd enter your name...
like, let's say off your badge.
And, uh...oh.
I should back up
just a little bit.
This demo was built,
and it's powered by
Google App Engine on the back,
and it's powered by Google
Web ToolKit on the front end.
And this is something that Don
and I just threw together
in like a couple days
just really quickly.
The second screen
you'd be presented with
is a screen
with a set of questions.
The top part of the screen
has an English phrase,
in this case,
"more than one way."
And underneath it,
it has several different
possible translations
for that phrase
in different languages.
And your job
playing this game would be
to determine
which of these phrases
is actually
the correct phrase.
And then after you make
an attempt at guessing,
it either tells you, you know,
hey, you got that right,
or, in this case,
no such luck.
While users are doing that
on their own local machines,
you can also have a scoreboard
up and running
which displays the total amount
of time running in the game--
it is a timed game--
and gives a list
of the top leaders
and their points.
And the way the points
are determined
is both in terms
of correct answers
and how quickly
those answers are corrected.
We're actually gonna
have you guys
help us test out
our demo live here.
But before we do that,
we're now going
to come over here
and talk just a little bit
about the code for the demo.
So like I said before,
this is based
both on App Engine
and GWT.
And if you're familiar
with GWT,
the way it works
is that...
if you wanna talk
to a backend server,
one of the common ways
of doing that
is using GWT RPC,
which is what we took
advantage of in the game.
We have two services,
one called the TranslateService
and another called
the AdminService,
And the translate service
is used for
the user side of the app where
people are playing the game.
So if we walk
through that some
and see some of the API,
or some of the function calls
we make available in this API,
there are things like
a login,
being able to see
if you're logged in,
retrieving information
about the current game...
the set of questions
that you would answer--
things along those lines.
And for the admin service,
for that scoreboard...
You're able to, again,
get information
about the current game,
you're able to start
a new game,
and you're also able
to finish the game.
So those are the interfaces
for the services.
And if we go and look
at the server side
of the application,
we see that those
are implemented
both in
two different services.
One is TranslateService.impl
and AdminService.impl.
And these are servlets
themselves.
So if we take a look through
TranslateService.impl,
we see that extends GWT's
remoteserviceservlet,
and it implements that
TranslateService interface
we just went through
and...
we see that there are bunch of
implementations of those APIs,
like the Login API
and the isLoggedIn
and getCurrentGame
and so on.
And if we look a little closer
at these APIs,
for example, getQuestions,
we can see that
they use these store objects,
like GameStore.
And if we go look
at GameStore...
we can see the purpose
of these store-based classes
is to wrap up the JDO logic.
So we're using the backend
datastore here
to store the questions
and so on.
I think that brings us
to the GWT client side of this
which Don is gonna talk about.
Schwarz: Um, sure.
So the...if you look at
the client part
of our infrastructure,
there's basically
two GWT modules.
One is the user view,
which is what
you're going to be seeing
when you play the game,
and the other
is an admin module,
which is what the scoreboard
that we're gonna have
up on the screen,
showing high scores
throughout the game,
that's how that's implemented.
So let's talk more about
the user view.
We used a simple
model view presenter type
implementation here
where we have
a presenter class
that contains all of our
actual control logic.
so each state change in the game
is represented here
as a method,
and it does things
like switch the current screen
and it fills out data.
And it does those using
view objects.
So each one of
the different screens
is presented as a view here.
And there's a GWT widget which
actually implements that view
and provides
all the display logic.
And then that brings us
to the model part
of the model view presenter...
paradigm
which is our model objects
up here.
And these model objects
are shared
not only inside of the client
to store data,
but they're also used
within the GWT RPC
as the transmit data between
the client and the server.
Reyelts: I guess that brings us
to the actual demo.
I hope--let's switch
machines here for a moment.
What we have here is a URL
that everybody can hit,
hopefully,
if you brought your laptops,
or even your mobile phones
hopefully should work.
If you hit
java-demo.appspot.com,
that should bring up
the application
we were just talking about.
We're gonna give you all
like 60 seconds or whatever
to pull it up.
Schwarz: And please log in
with your full name
as it's on your badge so we
can verify later the winners.
Schwarz: We can probably
get started.
People can always jump in
after we start.
Reyelts: All right,
so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna pull up
the scoreboard...
and we're gonna get
a game started.
When I click new game here,
what it's actually going--
it's going live to Google's
backend servers
and getting translations
for a bunch of English phrases
that we saw before.
So there we go.
So the game's just started
and you guys have...
4 minutes and 45 seconds
to finish.
Wow. That was quick.
Some people must
really know their Japanese.
[Schwarz laughs]
Reyelts: So you can see
in real-time
that what's happening here
is we're actually reading
from the datastore,
pulling these scores,
and we're actually limiting
the number of top scores.
Otherwise, we'd have a list
of 400 scores in the browser,
and those might be
hard to see.
And the GWT App is running
an active timer here too.
So the scores are being updated
once every ten seconds
or so.
I guess I should have
also mentioned--
or I may have already--
the quicker you answer
a question,
the more points
you're given for that question.
And so the server's actually
synchronized with the client.
The server determines
how many points
are assigned for a question.
Schwarz: [whispering]
Top three.
Reyelts: [whispering] What?
Schwarz: Top three.
Schwarz: We should
probably mention
that this demo's also using
HTTP sessions
to track, for example,
whether you've already
answered a question or not
and things like that.
And it's also using
a little bit of memcache to--
there's some polling going on
to figure out if the game
is done.
We're using memcache
to make that more efficient.
Reyelts: And in fact,
we have an implementation
of ApiProxy--
the profiling ApiProxy running,
which helped us determine
how much time we were spending
like in memcache
or the datastore calls
so we could optimize
as appropriate.
Schwarz: Should we pull up
the Admin?
Reyelts: If you want.
Schwarz:
I can get the log in here.
Reyelts: So what Don's
doing here
is he's pulling up
the Admin Console
for our application.
So earlier, at close to
the beginning of the talk,
I talked about
the Admin Console.
And it lists your applications,
and John just picks--
John. Don just picked the demo.
And, uh...so we can kind of
see a graph
of all the requests
we're seeing live
as we're running.
And you can kind of see that
like before, we were getting
very little traffic
because nobody was using
our app except for Don and I.
And now we're getting a much
higher amount of traffic.
Schwarz: And if you go
and look at the log files
for our application,
we should actually
be able to see...
those ApiProxy logging
statements
that Toby was talking about.
Just a few errors.
Those were earlier.
They're in info?
Reyelts: Yeah. They're warning.
Schwarz: So let's just
pick an arbitrary request here.
So you get some standard
information about the request
such as the incoming
IP address, etcetera.
And then these are
the individual API calls,
the login calls which are made
for each API service call.
So you can see approximately
how long each call took.
Let's go back to the scoreboard.
Reyelts: I was gonna say
it looks like
most people are finished.
Schwarz: I was gonna
ask that, yeah.
Reyelts: I think we can
cut if off now.
So, uh...so we'll just
do this...
which finishes the game now.
And we can see that
our top winners were
Joe, Dave, and Felicia.
If you guys wanna come up,
we actually have some T-shirts
for the top three winners.
[applause]
Schwarz: What size would you--
This is extra-large.
That's small.
Felicia: Okay.
Schwarz: So...yeah.
man: Thanks.
Reyelts: Congratulation, guys.
[applause]
Schwarz: Okay,
and we'll just end
by plugging a few features
that are upcoming
in App Engine.
Some of these features
actually have talks about them
at Google I/O,
so you definitely
want to check that out.
The first one
is task queues.
This is basically a way
to defer some work
that you want to do
during a request
to a future request.
So, for example,
if you run a social network
and someone chooses
to delete their profile,
there may be some expensive
cleanup that you need to do
to recover from that.
So with a task queue,
you can basically persist a task
and then return immediately
to the user
and then asynchronously
clean up all their data
and remove them
from social graphs,
perform other
responsive computations.
A full text search
is something that, being Google,
we're very interested in.
We'd also like to provide
incoming e-mail,
so you would essentially
get a callback
every time an e-mail
comes into your application...
as well as both inbound
and outbound XMPP support.
This will allow you to write
custom IM clients.
They're bots, basically.
Request and responses
are limited
to 10 megabytes right now,
but we'd like to support
large file storage
which basically lets users
stream larger files in
and for you to serve those files
back to users dynamically.
And then finally,
we know that datastore
import and export tools
are very important,
so we're constantly working
on improving those.
Reyelts: So what we'd like
to do at this point in time
is take questions from people.
If you have a question to ask,
we have microphones over here
and over here,
and that's important for us
so that we can record
the questions...
for you too.
Feel free to raise your hands.
man: Me?
Reyelts: Right there.
man: Does it work? Yes.
What would be the best place
to start services?
Something
that I have to start...when...
servlets...where servlets
take calls too.
Maybe little bit hard
to understand.
Let me phrase it
a little bit different.
So I have software calls
and they have calls
to other parts of my software
that need to be start up
in advance.
So where do I do that?
Best...
Reyelts: So...
so one thing you can do
is you can have work done
upon initialization
for a servlet.
Like the standard...
an ID on startup in a web.xml
will have code--
man: So that works.
Reyelts: Yeah, that will
work correctly.
And that doesn't mean
you can have
background running tasks,
but it does mean
that you can ensure
that code will run immediately.
And you can also use,
like Don mentioned,
you can use cron jobs to
continuously have work going on,
so you can schedule those
for like fairly
short periods of time.
And that can continuously
be running
like a background process too,
if that helps.
man: And if it takes
pretty long,
if it takes like 10, 20 seconds
to initialize certain services,
so every time a new server
comes into play...
there might be delay
of 10 or 20 seconds.
Is that correct?
Schwarz: This is a case
where task queues
may be very beneficial
to you.
So if you can do these
things asynchronously,
you could, for example, persist
something in the task queue
and then have something
constantly pulling
in the background
to pull things off
of the task queue
and implement the requests
in process.
I don't know if that directly
will solve your problem,
but that's sort of the direction
that we're going in.
man: Thanks.
Reyelts: Thank you.
We'll take one
from over here.
man: So I've been using
the early release of this
for a while now,
and one thing I've noticed
is it's really centric towards
using JDO as a datastore.
And I've typically
always used JPA,
at least recently.
Is there any plan to enhance
the capability of JPA,
or even best-case scenario,
adding some sort of
relational data model
to the datastore?
Reyelts: So JPA support
is definitely gonna be improved.
We wanted to get App Engine
support out as soon as possible,
and so JPA
is lagging a little bit.
But since it's through
the same middleware,
it's through DataNucleus,
in general,
most of that is done,
and we just...
and it ought to be
catching up shortly.
As far as the relational
support goes,
what we really want to do
is we want to help users
write apps
that will really perform
well on top of App Engine.
And unfortunately...
like the SQL you would use
in a lot of relational-style
stuff
does a lot of things
like joins
and stuff that you could do
on top of...
on top of our datastore,
but won't perform very well.
On the other hand, there are
people that are working
in the community,
on their own,
in order to support
relational, you know,
SQL-style programming.
In fact, I think like
the author of H2
is working
on something like that.
So you may see something
soon from them.
man: Great. Thank you.
man #2: I'm curious
how long it takes
to spin up a new JVM
when you need more JVMs
to handle requests,
and does that cause
a big hit to response time?
Schwarz: I would say
that it does cause
a noticeable hit to
response time at the moment.
We have some optimizations
in the pipeline
that would help improve that.
But I wouldn't say
it's something
that's a problem right now.
It's on the order of--
depending on how much
code you have
that actually needs
to be loaded and everything--
it's on the order of
anywhere between
several hundred milliseconds
to a second or two.
If you have a very,
very large library,
some of them are very
expensive to start up,
and it may be longer than that.
Reyelts: Yeah, so to talk
a little bit more
to what Don said,
there's time that it takes
to spin up a JVM,
and then there's time
that it takes
to actually initialize
your application.
So there's like
a decent amount of that
that's actually
under your control.
Like if you can delay a bit--
instead of like initializing
every part of your application
possible...
like let's say
on a servlet load,
if you can delay
parts of that application,
then the, you know, your
application will respond faster
on a new JVM
that has just been brought up.
But, yes, we're working on
faster initialization
of your code
and faster initialization
on the JVMs too as they spin up.
man: So how do the Python
and Java Engines
compare in performance
on their every load?
Schwarz:
That's a good question.
To be honest, we haven't
really done much profiling.
I'm seeing some
pathological cases
where Java performs
much, much better.
However, I would say overall,
the difference seems to be,
you know, what you would
expect intuitively
from Python versus Java.
I wouldn't say that
it's across the board...
many times faster
or anything to that extent.
There are just some cases
that Java does an extremely
good job of optimizing.
Reyelts: Yeah, and I would
say, in general,
for performance
on an App Engine,
you could expect to see
your Java code
run on roughly
the same order of magnitude,
the same expense as it would
off of App Engine.
So for example,
if you looked at Java versus
Python benchmarks, you know,
off of App Engine,
you should see about the same
relative performance
on App Engine.
Schwarz: We should probably
also say that Java Applications
tend to use a lot more code.
So there's a lot more
to actually...
there's a lot more
infrastructure involved,
whereas Python Applications
tend to be,
at least the ones written
with App Engine in mind,
tend to be much more
streamlined,
so that comes into it as well.
man: The demo you showed
used an HTML Application
as most App Engines demos are.
Does App Engine,
the Java App Engine
support anything like a remote
procedure call or anything
from outside Java land,
for example,
from an Android phone?
Reyelts: For example
for Android?
man: From a phone or some
other application
not sitting on your server?
Reyelts: Well, it accepts
HTTP requests,
so if you can formulate
whatever you're doing
in the term of an HTTP request,
like--
So for example,
you said we built an HTML App.
Yes. Yes, technically,
that's what it is,
but there's like GWT RPC,
right?
And GWT RPC
actually is interesting
because it's actually
a bi-mode kind of version
of communication.
It's, um...I forgot
the term we use exactly.
Asymmetric, I think.
And so, yeah,
like for example,
you could send serialized
Java objects, right,
over an HTTP request,
and that would work perfectly
fine under App Engine.
man: But it's all limited
to HTTP requests,
is that correct?
Reyelts: Right now. Yes.
man: Okay, thanks.
man: So my app needs
long-polling
Comet-like support.
Do you have any ideas
how I could do it?
Or if it's coming soon?
Schwarz: Um...do you want to...
This is Kevin Gibbs.
He's the Tech Lead
for App Engine, so...
Gibbs: That's all right.
Yeah, I know, we do hear
from time to time--
Probably
can people can hear me.
We do hear from time to time,
you know, people are
interested in Comet support...
[microphone background noise]
Right now, responses in
App Engine are not streaming...
man: Can you use
a microphone, please?
Schwarz: Sorry.
Gibbs: Does anyone...have one?
Schwarz: Here you go.
Gibbs: Oh, that's all right.
Schwarz: Oh. Got it? Okay.
Gibbs: Um...you know,
certainly, from time to time,
we do hear requests
from people,
they would like Comet support,
and Comet's great.
It's something
that's really exciting,
and I would love to see it added
to App Engine at some point.
You know, right now,
I think the...
the number of applications
that have Comet built into them
overall as a percentage
of applications is somewhat low,
and given that we have
finite resources for the team,
we're trying to tackle the tasks
that will help the most people
the most quickly.
So we are certainly interested
in providing it at some point.
It's not on the roadmap
right now,
but it's something
that we're looking into.
And I think that we do hope
at some point
for there to be some interesting
ways to accomplish this.
For instance, XMPP Support
is on our roadmap,
which you guys
might have seen.
And that will provide a way
of doing instant messages.
There may become a way for you
to use that with a browser
to do sort of more
push and pull.
But for straight-up Comet,
that isn't planned at this time
though it's something
we would be interested in doing
at some point in the future.
man: Hi there.
Does the JVM support
a HotSpot optimizer,
and if so, is it as advanced
as Sun's and IBM'S?
Schwarz: Go ahead.
Reyelts: I'm sorry.
Is it what IBM'S?
man: Well, I guess
two questions.
The first one is does
the JVM use a HotSpot optimizer?
Reyelts: Yeah, so the answer
to that is yes, we do right now.
And if you look at--
if you were to dig deep,
you would see right now
we're running
in the client compiler
and...
that is partially
to help make sure
that applications
load quicker.
Schwarz: Right, so specifically
we're using Sun's JVM,
out of the box, 1.6. with
the client HotSpot compiler.
man: Okay. So will you be
keeping up with
Sun's releases of the 1.6?
You know, I think they're at
13 now or something like that.
Reyelts: Yeah, absolutely.
We're really on top of that.
And we're always
looking at ways--
like for example,
there's tiered compilation
that would help
both speed up initial loading
and make code faster
as it's running.
And while we talk about
spinning JVMs up and down,
if your application
is getting hits,
that won't happen, right?
We won't arbitrarily
bring a JVM down for no reason.
So those are important
optimizations too.
man: And one final question.
Do you plan on supporting
the server of HotSpot optimizer?
Reyelts: Maybe.
We'll support
whatever turns out to be
the best optimizing compiler
across the entire set of load
that we see for applications.
man: Great. Thank you.
man: Yeah, I have two questions.
First, do we have plan
to support
the Admin Console
for the DAP Application Server
which is very useful
for the password.
Schwarz: Uh, yes, yes, we do.
The last release
was supposed to include
support for the dataviewer,
but it didn't quite
make it in in time.
But that will be available
the next release.
The other parts
of the Admin Console
are things that we have
on our roadmap.
I don't think we've spent
any time working on them yet
but definitely plan
to do so.
man: Okay. And my second
question is
can I deploy both Python
and Java into a same server?
Schwarz: So...you can have
an application
that runs both Java and Python.
What that means is that
you can take an existing
Python application
and deploy a separate
version of it on Java
and share the datastore
between them.
You cannot have a single
application version
that is both Java and Python.
Does that make sense?
man: Yeah. Thanks.
man: Are there
internal safeguards
put in place at Google
that restricts access
by Google employees to the data?
And if so, is there like
a white paper
or some published document
that shows that
so like for applications
that involve confidential data,
we could show that to the people
that are storing the data?
Schwarz: There are definitely
internal safeguards, yes.
In terms of do we have
anything published,
nothing I'm aware of.
So the question is are there
safeguards that prevent
Google employees
from seeing data,
and do we have anything
published
that expresses how we do that?
Gibbs: That's a good question.
Yes, there are safeguards
that prevent Google employees
from seeing the data.
And in general,
we apply the same policies
that we apply for
all of our other products
in our data center.
Things like Gmail, you know.
If you think about
the security concerns
with Google employees
in Gmail,
you know, those are
pretty important too.
And we do have
internal policies and ways
of dealing with that.
And we model those policies
and work in the same way
with App Engine.
There is actually a document--
I don't have a URL for you,
but is a white paper,
I believe,
about security
within Google Apps
and how we do security
and how that works
and how our policies work.
And that paper, generally
almost all of it applies
to App Engine.
I don't have a link
handy for you,
but I think if you Google
for it,
you might be able to find it.
Reyelts: All right,
are there any more questions?
Otherwise,
it looks like we're done.
Well, thank you, everybody,
for coming to our presentation.
[applause]